en esta aldea de nagorno karabaj a
decenas de familias empacan sus
pertenencias a su pesar es la segunda
vez que rafic y susan tienen que dejarlo
todo
no como la llaman los armenios es una de
las aldeas cedidas azerbaiyana tras los
acuerdos de alto el fuego en 2020
algunos prefieren quemar sus
pertenencias antes que dejárselas a los
azerbaiyanos estos habitantes se sienten
traicionados y olvidados
copeco que no es la primera vez que pasa
y el dinero no resolverá el problema no
es cuestión de dinero imagínense que
pierden su tierra tendrían que luchar
por ella la tierra en la que nací
esa es nuestra situación
nuestro karabaj a
la gente le escribe a eeuu a la unión
europea diciendo vengan a ayudarnos
para eeuu y la unión europea tiene
mejores cosas que hacer ni siquiera
pueden controlar a putin
[Música]
la pareja aún no sabe cómo llevarse a
sus vacas que son su única fuente de
ingresos
las autoridades de nagorno karabaj
ordenaron la evacuación de estos
armenios a raíz de la breve ofensiva
azerbaiyana de principios de agosto las
órdenes de evacuación afectan a tres
aldeas del corredor de la sin un eje
estratégico de unos cinco kilómetros de
ancho que conecta a estepa naker con
armenia a pesar de estas pérdidas
territoriales y de las incursiones
ocasionales de azerbaiyán en las
fronteras con armenia este analista no
teme una escalada militar en un futuro
próximo sino una crisis humanitaria
sin campo
azerbaiyán está aumentando el ritmo y la
presión para que los armenios de nagorno
karabaj tengan certeza sobre su futuro
ya lo vimos con el corte de gas del
invierno pasado
la presión sobre las telecomunicaciones
que se avecina
tal vez haya cortes
eso es una forma de anexión y famosa por
parte de azerbaiyán para intentar
apoderarse de nagorno karabaj o para
ayudar a los desplazados eso ngs están
movilizando ese es el caso del foro
armenia que retomó la ayuda humanitaria
de emergencia ante la afluencia de
familias desamparadas o hans compra
provisiones para rafic y susan que no
tienen nada en su nueva casa se
encuentran en una situación en la que
necesitan muebles y utensilios para
cocinar también están enfermos por lo
que tienen muchos gastos en medicamentos
pero esperamos que en el futuro reciban
más ayuda de la que podemos dar vidas
debería ser suficiente para
él
cuando la gente viene a vernos y es
amable con nosotros es un verdadero
apoyo psicológico nos permite no perder
la fe y la esperanza vivimos
sobrevivimos todo el mundo está en esta
situación no sólo somos nosotros
anses se va a ayudar a otra familia a
pocos kilómetros de distancia durante la
mudanza rafic se lesionó gravemente la
espalda a sus 75 años le es imposible
ordenar sus vacas
la solidaridad también se da entre
vecinos
y este vuelo me está ayudando a
recuperar efron de discriminarlo todavía
no han tenido fuerzas para desempacar
sus pertenencias la región de sonic
limítrofe con nagorno karabaj brindó
apoyo financiero y logístico para ayudar
a las familias a trasladarse y encontrar
alojamiento lugares a veces prestados
por particulares como en el caso de
rafic y susan que se instalan poco a
poco desilusionados y resignados
sabía que había acuerdos pero estaba
esperanzada
pero me estaba mintiendo a mí misma
pensaba como puede ocurrir esto nuestro
país dado tanta tierra como podría dar
más
mientras esté viva quiero ir a karabaj
libre
lo hecho hecho está
ahora continuará así
que tuvieron que huir de los turcos
estas son sus vacas
las ordeño las cuido sólo ayudó como
máxime muchos armenios temen que se les
cedan más tierras a azerbaiyán
no deberían haber seguido esta carretera
y ahora tienen acceso a esta carretera
tal vez incluso vengan a vivir a nuestra
aldea ya han entregado suficiente y
mañana vendrán y tomarán la región de
ara that y poco a poco seguirán tras
tener que abandonar su tierra los
armenios temen que haya una limpieza
étnica una carretera provisional
asegurada por las fuerzas de paz rusas
permite el paso de armenia a nagorno
karabaj a mientras avanza la
construcción de una nueva carretera
debido a las tensiones los armenios
deben ser expulsados de nagorno karabaj
si azerbaiyán bloquea el acceso a sus
aldeas